finally a game where i can have my team
roster be exclusively wolverine
and people he slept with hey you guys
like ultimate alliance
wish there was another one of those
games to play no not that one
x-men legends is a classic game and a
precursor to the ultimate alliance
series in pretty much every way
in some ways it's better than its
successor and in other ways it's
well really shows its age and it's kind
of lame and poopy and stuff
making this video was a pain in the ass
and i'd like to share that searing
pain with you dear viewer normally i
start these off by delving into some
backstory behind the game or asking a
larger question about it
or i guess trying to explain why that
particular game is important
but you know what i'm tired 2020 has
been a [ __ ]
year and i've been trying to review this
game since january
making this video is my moby dick it
just keeps haunting me and every time i
go after it i lose more and more
patience and sanity
this script is a jumbled mess of about
five different
drafts of various tones because i was
all happy and upbeat when i first
started writing this
and then i had to go to a bunch of
family funerals and then there was a sad
and depressed draft
and then i got incredibly burned out
from being overworked to make ends meet
after i signed a terrible deal with a
shitty multi-channel network who made
dozens of empty promises
before holding me under a contract and
sucking away 60 to 70 percent of my
monthly income for a year
[ __ ] you you lied to me and now there's
probably some stuff in there
written when i was feeling more neutral
and able to handle my emotions
this thing's going to be a train wreck
this is the youtube video equivalent of
cutting down a tree and counting all the
different colored rings
you'll see the layers of rage dating
back almost an entire year
so with that in mind here's a review of
a game that
kicked my ass
you know for someone who is named after
an x-men character i find myself not
often getting too
invested in x-men related stuff sure
i've watched all the cartoons because
the ex-boys managed to have three
awesome ones in a row
but that's kind of it read a lot of
wolverine solo comics but
other than that x-men weren't really my
thing so why am i reviewing this
game i've always gravitated towards
other characters
primarily ones that look like spider-man
but kill people
and also spider-man x-men legends review
requested by chris rodriguez on patreon
for the 100
tier if you have a topic for a review
that you desperately want to hear my
opinion on you can donate to that tier
or maybe one of these more reasonable
lower ones
if i like your suggestion i'll get
around to it eventually
[Music]
all right the game okay
the game i ain't going out like this
okay
okay
it's basically the same as ultimate
alliance except you can't punch guys
when you grab them if you haven't played
that
it's essentially an overhead dungeon
crawler with light rpg elements where
you can play as four
x-men at once unlike ultimate alliance
wolverine's healing factor is not a
character trait that happens
automatically
you have to buy that upgrade and it
sucks unless you level it up a bunch of
times
weirdly enough this game starts you out
with a single player mission
that's odd considering how fun the co-op
features are but this was the first game
of its kind and i suppose they didn't
realize how much people would like that
multiplayer aspect
we start off in the middle of a normal
day in mutanville where the mean old
homo sapiens have kidnapped some mutant
girl
who was then kidnapped by blob and
mystique from the humans and then
finally kidnapped by wolverine and
cyclops
but it's it's good it's cool when they
do it after getting passed around more
times than wolverine's nether regions at
cyclops and jean's wedding reception
mutant girl alison is taken to the
x-mansion and they try to recruit her to
the team since she's got some sick
radical powers
for the majority of the game you could
play as the x-men proper but you
experience the story and are introduced
to the world and characters
through allison it's kind of genius to
have a character that's just a normal
person going through their origin story
as a vehicle for the player to explore
all this
it's kind of like what they're doing
with kamala khan and that new avengers
game that everyone hates
it's also the opposite of x-men destiny
where you play as a boring nobody
character while all the cool and
interesting x-men just walk by and say
hello occasionally
i think it's also pretty neato that
unlike ultimate alliance almost every
line of dialogue in this game is voice
acted instead of just plain on-screen
text
and you are the name's jubilation lee
but everyone around here calls me
jubilee
you'd think that the future games
wouldn't have stepped down in that
regard but i
i think there was just less of it to
record for this one so it was more
manageable
the voice cast is pretty great with a
lot of a-list va's from the time
including steve blum
hey bub you should have called in sick
today
[Music]
this is his first time playing wolverine
which is pretty cool because a lot of
people consider him the definitive voice
for that character
and he's done it dozens of times even
recently and oh no never mind
oh [ __ ] they got patrick stewart for
this game
although it won't be easy my students
are quite fond of me
they call me professor x because you
look exactly like because i'm always
trying to sell them ecstasy
i think of all the games in this series
this one has the best hub world area to
explore between missions
you can go explore pretty much the
entire x-men man mansion
they have a decent take on every major
rumor location and every playable
xmensen has a unique bedroom that says
something about them and their
personality
oh hey it's iceman's room hmm
you must be bobby drake hey it's nice to
see my name's gotten around
did the other girls tell you what a cool
dude i am but enough about me
let's talk about you it's always nice to
meet a new student
especially one as pretty as you okay
bobby we don't have to have this
conversation today that's entirely up to
you
whenever you're comfortable i'm good but
you are trying
way the [ __ ] too hard all right enough
screwing around at the house time for a
mission
the brotherhood of mutants is causing
trouble in alaska so we go follow them
and stuff and things and [ __ ] this game
is hard
alright so i know i'm already playing
with a handicap by going through this
game solo when it's designed for four
players but that wasn't a problem in any
of the other
games in the legends and alliance series
two main issues gameplay-wise the way
you collect health and the way enemies
bombard you
when you take damage you have to
manually heal with one of these red
potion things
but they're limited and you have to find
them they don't restore very much health
and in a bind when your health is low
you may find yourself hammering the
button to use them and that drains your
supplies really fast
should one of the characters on your
team die they stay dead for the rest
of the level until you spend 200 of this
random currency to revive them
this isn't like the system and ultimate
alliance where you get health back from
beating enemies and every character can
come back after a short time delay
so they definitely improved on that in
the later games good job love you raven
software or whoever
god i hate the way this game floods in
dozens
and dozens of enemies this is the second
level in the game and i'm getting so
overwhelmed by enemies the only
character i can seem to keep alive as
wolverine because he has the
regenerating health upgrade
which i had to unlock enemies with
damage or health modifiers are thrown at
you so
commonly that you have to keep switching
up what character you're using to beat
them
in theory that's a good way to make
every character feel useful but all of
them except logan are made of cardboard
and break their necks on a gentle breeze
these enemies can even use a big
shockwave area of
effect attack that can set off
explosives and kill the whole team in
one move
to avoid that i have to either lure
enemies away from the thing or
shoot the explosives from a distance to
lower the risk
you can't have multiple save files for
whatever dumb reason so it just
overwrites the old one every time and i
have this constant anxiety
with each save that this will be the one
where i have such low currency
health and items that i could
potentially break the game and not be
able to progress anymore
these explosive barrels keep [ __ ] me
up i need to just stay at a distance and
lay me out by poking the enemies with
cyclops's beam
this is the same feeling i get when i
was first getting into survival horror
games
back then i wasn't as good with resource
management hoarding every item i ever
found
and being choosy about which enemies to
actually fight
when i started this game i figured it
would just be like any other third
person action thingy where you don't
have to take that stuff as seriously
look i know you're writing that comment
i can feel your dorito dust encrusted
keyboard clacking away so you can tell
me you were eight years old and beat
this game just fine
i don't care save it i'm supposed to be
honest about
my experience with the game yes i found
it difficult because i played a little
recklessly at the start of the game
no this does not mean my intelligence
and moral integrity are in question and
you should stop hovering your mouse over
that unsubscribe button sir or madam
jesus christ also this game is not bad
because it's hard i shouldn't have to
say that it's hard
because it's hard have you ever been
tired red
the [ __ ] barrels jesus christ
normally i just start jumping through
the level and avoiding enemies outright
but iceman is dead and i can't progress
until i revive him to use him to make
this bridge
so i'm caught in this infinite loop of
trying to fight this same small group of
insanely tough enemies
hoping they'll accidentally drop the
currency i need to revive a character
but whether or not it drops is
completely random from either enemies or
objects in the environment
i must have been stuck in this room for
hours i
i give up i i need to replay everything
up until this point
all right let's try this again
[Music]
it's been a few weeks this time i sprint
my way through everything
i collect and hoard resources like a
pack rat madman preparing for the
apocalypse
and all of its unresolved story threads
get stuck on this
furniture get off let me just
jesus pummel all the boss's ultimate
alliance style lose all of my team
except iceman and wolverine and
[ __ ] it i won't spend those revival red
crystal things until i'm past this
bridge i won't risk losing ice man
i have to make up for what happened god
there's so much
everything happening
we did it we made it everyone
oh my god i never thought i'd make it
past this trial
ah it's like it's like this game has
become a metaphor for my depression and
beating it i've overcome my perpetual
sadness oh this is only mission two
well depression's permanent moving on
moving on the gameplay gets a lot easier
if you just play it really aggressively
and make sure to level up the damage on
all of your ex-bros
my usual trick is to hammer the button
telling the ai partners to attack a
single enemy alongside spamming special
attacks so we stun lock every bad guy
one at a time
kinda like what they did to me before i
got past the stupid icebridge
alright relatively easy boss and back to
the x-mansion
getting the hang of this though even
with a more aggressive play style and
better resource management this game is
still
pretty difficult it really doesn't stop
with the overwhelming enemy numbers
i feel like i can never level up enough
to get a leg up on the problem
before these flashback sequences where
you play a few old x-men
stories it's important to save because
you can't revive your team during these
missions and it's yet another
opportunity
to get yourself permanently stuck my
strategy for fighting the sentinels is
to stand practically between their legs
because you're so close to them they
can't figure out how to target you and
just shoot lasers wildly at the floor
past your head
i'm noticing a pattern here where
progressing the game and fighting basic
enemies requires a lot of brute force
and it feels really awkward and
exhausting this isn't a game i can just
turn off my mind and play
i gotta really hunker down and focus or
i'm going to get stuck again
i guess that's the biggest overall issue
with this gameplay
it's not fine-tuned or polished enough
to be comfortable
and always feels stressful this really
does feel like an unfinished prototype
for later games by the same developers
and because of that it's not really all
that fun for me
playing this game feels like manual
labor instead of a fun adventure
you never feel like x-men legends
god these morlocks are so violent come
on fellas remember that christmas
special i thought we were on good terms
oh wait no one watched that
beyond that this game doesn't offer much
else story is pretty basic and serves to
just get you into a handful of
recognizable x-men locations
like the morlock tunnels laboratory in a
snowy forest that's where i quit writing
my script about five months ago i just
wanted to focus on other videos that
would be more fun to make or
spending time with my loved ones because
life is too short to just be miserable
all day on purpose
i haven't ever left a game review
unfinished before but i don't know what
else to do
this game isn't fun for me it's just
tedious
the whole point of a game is to have fun
arguably the greatest game reviewer of
all time has had a history of only
halfway finishing games but he's also
kind of earned that
if only someone could come in and talk
about the later half of this game so i
could rest
to me my x-men
[Music]
oh there's uh only one of you
okay hey xavier hello
not you baldi looks like you could use a
hand
boy do i let's do a fastball special mr
has the game on pc man
well pc is the superior race
old friend
diego oh all right we're doing this hey
what's up everyone beast oh beast come
on
put some shoes on nobody wants to smell
that rogue hey
how's it going you uh doing anything up
no it's cool
all right hey i was told wolverine was
gonna be here
i wanted to show him a shirt no not
today
all right that's cool anyone got a one
lighter no
me all right let's do this everyone
please subscribe to my channel after
this
if only me and xavier weren't separated
by thousands of miles
and a global pandemic worse than the
x-men movie's continuity
we could have played this game how it
was meant to be played
over a weekend sleepover stacks of pizza
boxes
and wholesome couch co-op but we'll
settle for the next best thing
online multiplayer nah this game's old
well we can't play the game co-op but at
least we can carry on the sentiment by
splitting this review in half between us
to echo some of xavier's thoughts this
game shows its age by having a number of
design flaws that result in the game
straight up getting locked
having character specific environmental
puzzles is a cool idea
but having those characters be
inaccessible after dying
unless you have enough of the limited
currency to revive them
that can be found within levels is an
obvious game breaking problem
and it's weird how most of them require
iceman
nothing against the guy but he is so
vital he should have been slapped in the
middle of the box art
other issues that were eventually ironed
out in its successor
marvel ultimate alliance are the health
and energy pickups
having these be energy orbs that
automatically gravitate towards the
player
allows for your focus to solely remain
on combat
especially since things can get really
hectic having to constantly glance at
your health bar and making sure that you
don't exhaust your resources
ruins the pace of combat i do think
combat feels a bit better in x-men
legends
your kicks and punches feel impactful
they're supported by good sound design
and the fact that the screen has this
slight shake every time you land the hit
on an enemy
this was missing in marvel ultimate
lines and it made the combat feel more
hollow by comparison
and this may seem like a bit of a
nitpick but it was really underwhelming
not having a number of different
costumes for each
x-men seeing all the different costumes
you can put on your heroes and ultimate
alliance was one of my favorite parts of
the game
here there isn't much variety alright
let's get this quest to stop the
brotherhood on the road
gambit was being held captive by the
morlocks after they caught him spying on
them
he overheard them planning to get in
cahoots with the brotherhood
after rescuing him it's off to a ship
carrier where we need to stop the
brotherhood from freeing magneto
i like this level quite a bit since
there's a point where the ship starts to
fall apart
and the team needs to use their powers
to hold it together
like using cyclops optic blast to weld
the steel walls shut
well hold on i thought his blasts were
concussive
god dammit figure it out guys you also
have to escort shipmates to safety
i love these kinds of simple heroics in
the midst of stopping a world ending
ploy
magneto manages to escape and makes a
broadcast waging war against humanity
and with no time to waste professor x
says [ __ ]
we're gonna need all the help we can get
and officially recruits miner
alison into the x-men irresponsible best
what follows are a bunch of detours to
get across what essentially is a pretty
by the numbers x-men story
of stopping magneto from ending homo
sapien life
stuff we've seen before like the mansion
getting raided by sentinels
and going through the weapon x facility
where mutants are being experimented on
there's an interesting setup for a boss
fight between havoc and cyclops
their powers don't work against each
other because they're brothers
so using any one of your special
abilities is pointless
i thought this was a cool idea but in my
playthrough havoc just kind of gave up
halfway through the fight
and just stood there fight me brother
so i just [ __ ] him up with barrels
these games are at their best when we
get to go to outlandish locations like
the astral plane
this level is easily one of the best
since it's in a fun setting
and we get to play as an overpowered
professor x all the frustrations of
getting mobbed by enemies are gone when
you can wipe out a whole group with one
attack
the team goes to this realm to find out
what's wrong with colossus's sister
iliana she's in a coma but they can't
find anything physically wrong with her
this ends up being a trap set up by the
shadow king an evil entity that dwells
in the astral plane
he takes professor x out of commission
leaving his psyche trapped in the astral
plane
and the x-men without their leader it's
at this point that i realize the game
gets a lot easier in its latter half
i mean it makes sense since your team
has been leveling up and increasing
their stats
but it's also as backwards to start a
game so frustratingly hard
that it discourages players to continue
playing give me all the father enemies
first that do low damage
and allow for me to level up at a
reasonable pace
then start easing in the tougher enemies
to match my
homo superior a couple of detours later
involving a new type of sentinel being
developed by general kincaid
who has a huge hate boner for mutants
and magneto covering the earth and
freaking asteroids blocking it from the
sun's rays
geez talk about a power move the x-men
eventually figure out a way to make it
back to the astral plane
professor x escapes the astral plane
after a big goofy kaiju fight against
the shadow king
this is the type of [ __ ] i'm here for
it's finally off to the big final
mission where we storm asteroid m
magneto makes three demands that must be
met if mankind wants to see the sun
again
all anti-mutant programs are to be
stopped he wants the island of jenosha
as a sovereign nation
and general kincaid's ass the military
responds by sending sentinels to space
and firing upon asteroid m
thus sending the asteroid on a crash
course towards new york city man our
homo sapiens stubborn
hashtag magneto was right am i right
after wiping the floor with magneto with
my overpowered team of inn mutants
general kincaid shows up with a weapon
to surpass sentinels
a bigger sentinel so while this fight
mainly consists of mindlessly attacking
an overpowered sentinel
i liked that i ended up using just about
every x-men in the roster
this hunk of junk kept taking out every
single one of my ex-pals
so running over to an extraction point
to tag heroes with each fallen comrade
makes it feel like the whole team is
coming together for one big
insurmountable task
once the super sentinel is taken out the
rookie of the team steps up to stop the
asteroid from crashing into earth
and she just [ __ ] kills everyone man
it's a pretty messed up ending
one last thing no allison
wait
[Music]
nah just kidding she did great mankind
eats their words
and the world is safe thanks to the
x-men but it's not a complete comic book
video game without a stinger setting up
the sequel
we get a quick scene of apocalypse
watching a long play of x-men legends
and promises part 2 will one-up it in
every way
i'll hold you to that big blue huh
so that's how it ends yup it's not a bad
story
nor is it groundbreaking but much like
marvel ultimate alliance
it's about those character interactions
and learning about the x-men's history
that sells it for me i didn't want to
hate this game and i still don't
but it's clear that this was an early
draft for better games down the line
it was lacking so many quality of life
features that would make it more
relaxing and accessible
changing the health and respawn system
ever so slightly would have made it a
vastly different and more enjoyable
experience
as proven by how beloved ultimate
alliance was
but even if this game was flawed and
even a little bit busted
we owe it a lot because without it we
wouldn't have one of the best superhero
games out there
hey x i bet you a hundred bucks i can
get you to review
x-men legends too no no way no i'm not
going near that game i've been reviewing
this one since
january i need a break darn
you win fair and square see i don't
carry any cash
is it cool if i pay you through patreon
sure
whatever hey it says here i can request
a review at the 100
tier you
keep your damn money
[Music]
[Music]
you